Dems pop their Dentures when Schiff
finally gets censored and so the house
condemns the lies of the man with the
zombie eyes
last night the house voted on party
lines of censure Adam Schiffer promoted
the Trump Russia collusion hoax which
was as believable as Brian Kilmeade
getting fan mail
two for two
shift becomes only the 26th member ever
to be censured but to his credit he's
still the only member to have a 12-inch
neck
yeah what'd you think I was going to say
being censored which is basically an
official serious scolding is a
punishment just below being expelled
from Congress but when speaker McCarthy
made the announcement Democrats did what
they do best mindlessly scream
hysterical nonsense
adopted without object the motion to
continue laid on the table
[Applause]
the house will be in order
I have all night
um I have all nights if I had a nickel
for every time Stuart Varney told me
that
but Dems wouldn't shut up for a party
named after democracy itself they do
sure hate it when people vote on stuff
but he did have to go to the front of
the chamber known as the well think of
it as like you know like a walk of shame
and not the kind I did this morning
leaving Hammer's place
I only had one shoe
to discuss this further we go to the man
himself an audience no booing we are a
respectful show here please welcome
Congressman Schiff how are you
[Music]
shame on you oh yeah oh excuse me Mr gut
fell so Congressman I gotta ask how did
it feel to have your ass chewed out like
that in front of your colleagues oh well
I will say this Mr Gutfeld it feels
wonderful I was just listening to my
colleagues chanting Shame Shame Shame
it's music to my ears uh yesterday's
hearings I had so much fun
I'm back baby pretty soon I'll have my
high back Chairman's chair again
hmm
[Music]
understand you're happy I didn't realize
you were uh don't you realize that you
were censored by a majority in Congress
yes isn't it wonderful and very
pro-censorship excuse me
ship oh my that's hard to say the point
is the cameras are on me again and this
time I'm ready for my close-up Mr
DeMille
that's very strange and I'm troubled by
this
even though I know it's not real I'm
bothered finally Congressman you're
running for an open U.S Senate seat in
California what's your message to voters
who might be skeptical of your agenda uh
I think you mean my again uh that's how
I say it now I like the hard G because
that's what I'll do do you like
impeachment that's my agenda vote for me
and I'll do it again duh
and I have one man to thank for all of
this the orange man himself
if you excuse me I'm gonna go celebrate
with a glass of wine and some Trump
Stakes good night ladies and gentlemen
shame on you thank you Congressman Chef
uh all right
uh Paul does this mean anything nobody
in America knows what censored means
right nobody really knows that much
about the implications of the entire
thing so no I don't think it means a
whole lot and he's playing you know he's
playing into it but you know he's gonna
get his reward here he's likely going to
get that big seat the senate seat in
California because he's been there
attack dog knows where a lot of the
bodies are buried they got to take care
of him he does look like he was goosed
with a cattle prod but that doesn't seem
to bother anybody and uh you know he's
gonna be around we better get used to
that uh I mean the guy looks like a
praying mantis I mean yeah I'm looking
for the antenna it is one of the oddest
looking people on the planet and it make
I guess he makes it work Tyrus but does
he I don't but is it I mean I don't want
to get mad about this because he's such
a joke but the fact that he isn't going
to be really uh the get any punishment
at all yeah it's like
don't do it again punishment from your
mom when she knows I'm gonna do it again
yes but I guess she didn't feel like
giving me a spanking tonight I mean he's
gonna use this as a campaign tool that's
the and it goes back to the that the
point in that creepy interview that we
just watched the the point that he was
making was all this is doing is putting
me back in the Limelight it's opening up
his platform it's going to get him more
donors and going to give him a better
shot to get that seat that he so wants
and that's the problem that's the
problem we have in this country as long
as it's not happening to my side of the
street I don't care what's going on the
other side but eventually it all comes
around and that's where people wrong is
wrong and we need to get back to that
what this man did is he led a quiet coup
with no facts and disrupted the country
for basically all of four years of of
President Trump's term non-stop so that
to me should bother everybody not just
somebody but this is the time we live
right now it's really disappointing that
a censorship which a lot of
previous centers would have resigned
over yeah this guy's trying to get a
promotion yeah there's a problem with
that yeah you know cat maybe the
punishment is that he has to be trapped
in the life of Adam Schiff that is is I
don't know if he has any does he have
family or friends I don't know he
doesn't seem like he would
yeah I I don't think he's bothered by it
I think again I do I do agree I think
that he just loves to be on TV again and
when you kind of set it up as he has
that all Republicans are evil horrible
people being censored by evil horrible
people he sees as a win and like Tyra
said everything is just based on whether
something's bad or good is it on my side
then it's then it's good and if it's on
the other side then it's bad even though
this is was very clearly objectively bad
and he wasted money that every taxpayer
the government spends her money and
everyone should be mad it should be so
easy to be mad but we're so far gone
that at this point that people can't get
mad at somebody if they're on their own
side what say you Julie have you ever
been censored
um yes but it starts with the
s-e-n-s-o-r-e-d that happens on this
show almost every time exactly but no
I've never been censured um but I have
to say you know as the former chairman
of the house intelligence committee this
is really disturbing because he had a
duty to deliver the truth to the
American people okay and what he did
instead was he lied to the American
people he told the American people that
there was actual evidence of Russian
collusion and the majority of America
actually believed it right people that
voted for Biden basically believed it so
not only did he hamper that election but
he basically we got all stiffed by
Schiff I mean that's essentially what
happened and then the guy first of all
zero accountability in Washington he's a
living proof for it and then not only
that he was ordered to pay 16 million
dollars which would have only covered
half of the costs that we paid for a
special investigator Mueller I know
you're shocked that I know all these
facts I'm amazed I forgot you're on the
hard news side so we spent over 30
million dollars getting a special
investigator to Robert Mueller we spent
all this money and what where does that
money go there's there's no
accountability whatsoever and now he's
going to run for Senate it's incredible
it's disgusting I've never been more
pissed off by getting stiffed by anybody
there she is I'm back yes
I know what happened just bleep that
whole part out yes you know the facts
exactly all right we got to move on up
next they called her precocious but her
predictions were atrocious hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else